John Bongiovi could easily be a Star
Wars character he's just missing a - he
has a pudgy body and 18 arms he's
portrayed through motion capture by you
and McGregor
[Music]
okay I think I think I think so
hi welcome everybody to millennial
Falcon weekly this week I had a topic
and then something really weird happened
on the way in I found this manila
envelope just lying in the hallway and I
opened it and inside it looks like it's
the leap script for the obi-wan movie
whoa did you hear they were making that
I heard I read the reports but I can't
believe they have a script on it looks
like it's a work in progress script for
the film so I I don't really want to
talk to you anymore that's okay yeah by
the way this is Dan Casey of Nerdist
thank you for having me I appreciate it
well there's no point to it now cuz
we're pretty much just gonna look at
this script I love PDF copy what what
what could be you down below oh my
goodness yeah well then why don't you
take qui gonn alright give off that vibe
to me thank you
well I'm gonna die early yeah pretty
much yeah you're not here for multiple
episodes yeah the vibe you give off
exterior stooge on a desolate desert
planet qui gonn stands by his ship
looking through a pair of space
binoculars at the barren landscape a
small boy obi-wan Kenobi treks across
the dunes he's an orphan rock carrier
which is an even sadder thing to be than
a normal orphan a slave with a mom or an
orphan scavenger qui gonn seized the
rocks in his arms and calls out to him
you their youngling
golly what is it mister those rocks
you're carrying I believe they're geodes
containing Kyber crystals I scanned them
with this khyber locator which now
exists and is permanently a part of Star
Wars canon their reading is 800 it means
they are very powerful Kyber crystals
Wow sorry mister but I need to bring
these rocks to monger slump sack I'm one
of his rock carriers just then monger
slump sack appears on the horizon you
there boy stop talking to that Jedi yeah
those rocks are gonna carry themselves
monger slumps sack is a seed
I'm monster who looks like if Gumby was
obese and very very angry his arms are
20 feet long he is portrayed through
motion capture by Andrew Garfield qui
gonn frowns does your master treat you
well youngling he's not my master he
just owns me and tells me what to do
that sounds like what a master does Oh
what is it you do for him I pretty much
just carry heavy rocks from point A to
point B point B is the name of the city
where I live and he's a friend of yours
no he's mean and disgusting I only
worked for him so he doesn't slap me
with his noodley arms anyway I'm sorry I
can't help you mister well maybe I can
help you I'll carry some of your burden
in exchange for one of these geodes no
that's okay when they get too heavy I
just carry them with my amazing mind
powers mind powers that sounds like you
have the force golly you really think so
if it's true you can leave this life
behind and come with me and train to be
a Jedi and go on amazing adventures
Wow and what if it's not true only of
you here to go on suffering neat well
then let's test me oh no I don't have a
midi-chlorian scanner with me they are
very expensive and not easily portable
we're at least a decade away from having
that kind of technology as a handheld
device oh that's some foreshadowing I
guess exactly I love these tie-ins to
the precursors yeah but we can run the
test if you come with me to a Jedi
Temple the closest one is on my home
planet Star Wars land galaxy's edge
there's so much to do and see there
let's go so okay it looks like it's not
a complete script but I think what we
have here is really strong this is
something that we haven't seen before
and that is super so a kid growing up in
a desert working a miserable job it's
such a unique take for him you see he
found that in the hallway though yeah it
was very strange that's weird because
when I was walking in I also found a
manila envelope in the hallway it's also
an obi-wan it's also an obi-wan script
and there's two collars two copies oh my
gosh so it's another little
work-in-progress it looks like it's just
a page draft
he is a young roguish obi-wan he's 21
years old and is played by Chris
right that make sense he looks 21 people
suddenly an alien thug approaches from
behind he's swinging a space club
menacingly he has a pudgy body and 18
arms he's portrayed through motion
capture by you and MacGregor's yeah I
love how they're not goes back that's so
clutch excellent
Kenobi you've got a lot of nerve showing
your face around here
whoa Buffy bro living on a prayer starts
playing obi-wan runs through an alley
and more bad guys cut him off at the
other end he skids to a stop bugging out
his eyes comically and pinwheeling his
arms I love a soundtrack that his songs
that I know yeah exactly I want to be
able to sing along while I'm watching a
movie I don't care about John Williams
no he dies through the window next to
him and begins running through connected
storefronts stumbling over merchandise
as he goes a fat shop owner woman says
oh well I never
sorry ma'am he tastes the stew cooking
on the pot great rathtar stew obi-wan
keeps running through buildings then he
freezes he is in a shop owned by a sexy
alien babe she looks pretty by earth
standards but her skin is purple and she
has tattoos so we know she's an alien
she stands with her arms crossed looking
unhappy Kenobi you slept with me and
never texted me back what can I say babe
Jedi can't have emotional attachments I
hate the script I mean this obi-wan is
very roguish and sexy so I guess he
would resonate with audiences like a
fast and furious meets guardians of the
galaxy meets Star Wars and Chris rad is
even there I just got chills he he's
like me but richer you're just like him
yeah Wow Oh JT you're super late you're
very late man I went to Arby's and I
found this script an Arby's yes oh okay
that's weird
hey yeah it's another obi-wan skirt what
and there's two copies oh my god that's
so I would ruin Arby's
well why don't you just take this one
okay 25 year-old obi-wan fires a missile
at the Sith spaceship the Sith spaceship
dodges and shoots lasers back give you
sorry I ad
no that is tortilla lies a little bit
getting in the spirit yeah the lasers
from obi-wan ship hit an asteroid
instead in the asteroid explodes right I
love a space battle cut to another ship
we can only see the outside of the ship
so we can't remember who's in it the
ship blows up to SIF box whoa
sit bots yeah it's this addition to kit
light the shockwaves of the explosion
send their ships spiraling out of orbit
interrupts into flame cut to interior
nearby Republic space Starcraft a bunch
of unfamiliar aliens are standing in the
hallway one has broccoli for a head the
other looks like a human but with weird
hands the third looks like a hot babe
but she's purple and has tattoos
corporal Remer stuck evasive maneuvers
we're taking on heavy fire I hope
they'll be okay I hope so too
corporal seems pretty concerned yeah
detectives squish Cobra squish squish a
Cobra we must get the memory disk to the
rendezvous point
Darth Vader pulls out his lightsaber
stalks down the hall Darth Vader is here
oh my god Samy alien Oh No Darth Vader
starts cutting things with this red
lightsaber Oh awesome
guards start running and somersaulting
out of the way Darth Vader uses his
force choke to choke some guys yes this
is my favorite one yet
I'm glad they found a way to work in
Darth Vader and Obi Wan's use exactly it
would be so boring if Darth Vader wasn't
in it I really couldn't tell any part of
his story without Darth so what was your
favorite of these takes I'm gonna guess
that the first one was written by George
Lucas just based on the Sharpie writing
on it that said please read it Kathleen
I don't know I think my favorite of all
of them is probably script number three
now when had Darth Vader Darth Vader and
I just need to know more about detective
squishy Cobra because he kind of sounds
like he's gonna bring some of that like
gritty sort of crime element that I
loved about like obi-wan rejecting death
sticks in the bar yeah it was like I
don't know I think it feels like it was
written by someone who understands the
flow of a battle scene I get one I did
like it because it had a song
recognized might be going on a limb here
but I bet they could make a pretty cool
music video - the ending credits oh
you're totally right and then they would
cut away two characters from the film
dancing and celebration of having
survived this big adventure together you
want it's supposed to be fun yeah the
whole family if I have children someday
I want them to hear living on a prayer
and go it's the song from Star Wars
because they think that's what invented
it Jon Bon Jovi could easily be a Star
Wars character he's just missing a -
yeah and we can add that in no problem
exactly what's he gonna do ask us to
correct it he wouldn't dare all right
well I guess that's all the scripts I
should have put a big spoiler warning at
the beginning spoiler too late now I
guess it's time to hear from you the
audience it's time for general
grievances oh I like that and you know
what you do during general grievances do
I sit here silently and accept their
grievances you are gone oh okay well
yeah I suppose cool uh cool read this
salon out of it there you know please be
very careful with our equipment okay
just drop it on the floor
all right first comment is from chaco
Toco Toco Toco who said funny thing is
general grievances sounds like a Star
Wars knockoff character that's the joke
yep that's mom we did that on purpose
okay
next comment is from God mode enabled
one who said the female host is super
obnoxious and ruins what could have been
a great video the videos probably don't
have a chance at greatness either way I
don't think it's really fair to pin it
all on me
it's butyl II the guests fault to be
honest all right last comment is from
Phil Michael's film a man bill said yeah
but nerd crew didn't have a
stereotypical hot chick that doesn't
like any nerd stuff but pretends to like
it for a paycheck um I guess that was
meaning he didn't call me a
stereotypical hot chick so I guess
that's fine you could stay Phil you're
you're all right in my book okay and
that's all the comments everyone leave
your nice comments below in the box for
comments the comment box and then I'll
read them maybe I'll read three of them
anyway bye bye everybody
yeah good okay that's the episode that's
it
you